regarding the taliban and their their
reemergence is
very much concerning it is something
that not just afghanistan in the region
but especially europe should be very
much concerned about it because
it will have two immediate impacts
besides many other impact it will have
the two immediate impact
first it's the rise of genio wave of the
young extremists and fanatic people
in the in the west the second thing is
new wave of
immigrants and afghanistan's region's
afghanistan's security and stability
will affect the region
and the displacement of afghans and also
some other people around in the region
most of them they will head back to
europe and they will head
to europe uh for for for safety and uh
and for for hope and for future so
immigration a new wave of immigration
and also
uh the potential
rise of new wave of extremists coming
from europe to afghanistan
because they see that a sort of
extremist narrative have taken
over a state it is very dangerous
who do you blame for this complete mess
well first of all i blame americans most
more than anyone
the deal they made with the taliban they
gave them the moral boost that they
needed
and a sort of recognition that they
needed
so i blame for such a mess right now the
americans more than anyone and then
the afghan administration not just now
for the past 20 years
that they were unable to really
establish
a functioning estate what is your
capability
in taking on the taliban because i guess
that's what everyone wants to know
well myself i have a commitment
to the people of afghanistan as a new
generation
our previous generations they all
vow to to serve this country and to help
it to support it to defend it
and we new generation we are like you
know we are vowing to do the same thing
to really defend the values of
afghanistan the values of afghan people
and and and to defend this country what
makes you think
the people here would be prepared to
fight and how many i mean are we talking
hundreds or
thousands so the people of afghanistan i
can say in
thousands of thousands they are ready to
pick up arms to join the uprising group
to join the anna
the groups that wants to defend this
country and the problem
is the lack of ammunition and weaponry
and also of course
resources which is the most important
thing particularly
myself once again i need to emphasize on
on the fact that
i'm just a politician that have been
left
no choice but to actually do something
in defending this country and defending
this land and my especially my
constituency
because the uh the thing is that i have
not attacked anyone i have not
went to any in a country or any
constituency to empower or or like force
my own idea and believe on them
uh but we are need to defend our own
valleys our own home our own country
because
there has been a war coming at us so i'm
just a politician
trying to do something for my country
and there's no choice left for us but to
stand and defend our country
you're not afraid of dying because there
are people who want you dead
well no one can say oh i'm not afraid of
dying
of course i am afraid of dying but what
is more
sacred cause than defending the people
the innocent defending the civilian
and defending democracy
do you know people rights humans right
women's right freedom of his speech and
freedom above all
what's more sacred than defending that
if
it takes my life well i lived a very
meaningful life
you mentioned your warning um because
um the west britain europe
were left sleeping with isis yeah there
were there were warnings but they
ignored it yes until it exploded
absolutely
is that is the same thing what's your
feeling about much much worse than that
because uh the thing about the iraq is
that the geography
was easy to really for for the
international
coalition forces to push back the the
the isis and to really to target them
but this geography of afghanistan is
very difficult and hard
so it is going to be much much more
difficult
and so i hope that there shouldn't be or
there won't be any numbness
and regarding afghanistan situation and
this time they listen to the warning
they say they've changed the taliban say
they've changed that they're more
moderate
do you believe them in any way no they
have not changed
they do not want peace they do not want
to establish a just and good government
a moderate one they want to establish an
extremist
narrative government a cruel
and violent government with sort of
extremist plans for the country they
want an afghanistan off
completely under the blanket of darkness
but we do not want that and the people
of afghanistan do not want that